字幕: Takumi TSUBOTA
校正: Koichiro YODA
（石田の代弁）みなさん こんにちは
僕の名前は 岡﨑と言います
生まれた時から
耳が全く聞こえません
みなさんは 聞こえない人に
どんなイメージをお持ちでしょうか？
「手話で会話する人」
「しゃべれない人」
いろんなイメージがあると思います
でも 実際は
手話ができる人もいれば
できない人もいる
しゃべれる人もいれば
しゃべれない人もいる
みんな 人それぞれです
聞こえ方もみんなバラバラです
僕の場合はどうなのか
僕の場合はー
（岡﨑）しゃべります
（笑）
しゃべることが大好きです
そして 手話を愛しています
皆さんは「手話」ってご存知ですか？
手話っていうのは
今 僕が使っている
手を動かして話す言葉です
一個一個の動きに意味があり
すべてが言葉になっています
今の社会は 声で会話するのが
当たり前だと思います
耳が聞こえない僕にとって
声の会話というのは
中身を理解するのに
とても苦労します
耳が聞こえないので
耳で聞く代わりに
目でみんなの口の動きを見て
何をしゃべっているのか
口の動きから頑張って
読み取っているんです
正直 疲れます
朝から夜まで
ずーっと口ばっかり見ていたら
疲れます
（笑）
それに 相手の話し方によっては
頑張って口の動きを見ていても
何をしゃべっているのか
さっぱりわからない時があります
たとえば
口をはっきり開けない人！
しゃべるのが早い人！
手で口を隠しちゃう人！
（笑）
もう！
こんなふうに 日常生活の中では
口の動きが読み取りにくい状況が
いっぱいあります
なので 会話の中身がわからなくなるときも
正直 いっぱいあります
だけど 手話ならば
そんなことはありません
手話ならば 頑張らなくても
みんなの話が自然と理解できるんです
僕にとっては
最高の言葉だなって思っています
だけど この国で手話ができる人は
たったの0.06%です
1,500人に１人だけなんです
少ないですよね
僕は この手話を
もっとたくさんの人に
知ってほしい！覚えてほしい！
使ってほしい！って思っています
なので 今日はこの場を借りて
皆さんに手話のいいところを
お伝えしたいと思っています
この残された時間で
僕が どれだけ皆さんに
手話に興味を持ってもらえるか
僕にとって
人生で大きなチャレンジです
頑張ります
それでは さっそく行きましょう
手話の良いところ
まずは こちら！
［手話の良いところ①］
いろんなところで会話ができるー！
皆さんは こんな状況 —
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
皆さんは こんな状況
ありませんか？
「わー 離れているから
声が届かないよー」
「わー 周りがうるさいから
聞こえないよー」
「あー 風邪をひいて
声が出ないよー」
あると思います
でも
（三人）大丈夫！
（笑）
（岡崎）手話は 視覚的な言語です
声の大きさや周りのうるささなんて
関係ありません
そう 離れてても
（三人）大丈夫！
（岡崎）うるさくても
（岡崎）声が出なくても
（三人）大丈夫！
（岡崎）そう 見えていれば
最強の言語なんです
もう少し具体的にお話ししましょう
手話があると このような状況でも
会話することができます
ぱっ！
［静かにしないといけない所］
日常生活では
（笑）
静かにしないといけない状況って
いっぱいありますよね
たとえば 図書館
（中川 石田）しーっ
（岡崎）美術館
（岡崎）電車の中
（中川 石田）しーっ
（岡崎）赤ちゃんが寝ている部屋の中
（岡崎）そして 夜の遅い時間
（中川 石田）しーっ
そんなときって
周りに迷惑にならないように
静かにしなきゃって思いますよね？
でも
（三人）大丈夫！
（岡崎）手話は そんなときに
声を出さなくても
静かに会話することができるんです
便利ですよね
そして 声を出さなくても
会話ができるということは
こんなところでも会話ができるんです
ダン！
［海の中］
海の中です
（笑）
僕は 前に友達と一緒に
沖縄の海にダイビングしに
行ったことがあります
その時は 海の中で
しゃべるのはもちろん
僕たちは海の中で歌を歌っていました
皆さん 海の中で歌を歌ったら
何が起こるか知っていますか？
魚が逃げます
（笑）
まぁ 楽しかったですよ
僕たちはそんなことまで感じて
海の中で会話を楽しんでいたんです
手話があったおかげで
海の中でも
いっぱいしゃべれて 歌えて
その場の感動をその場で
共有することができたんです
手話だからこそできる
新しい楽しみ方ですよね
そして 手話があると
こんな時にも便利です
［電車の窓越し］
（笑）
ラブラブなカップルは一分一秒でも
長く一緒にいたいと思います
そんな時に さみしいのは
電車でのバイバイのシーン
普通のカップルならば
電車の扉が閉まったら
ハイ そこで会話終了
（笑）
ですが
手話の場合は
（石田）プシュー
（中川）あぁ
（石田）バイバイ またね
（中川）うん
（石田）バイバイ またねー
（岡﨑）うん！
このように
電車のドアが閉まった後も
最後まで会話を
続けることができるんです
一分一秒でも長く
おしゃべりしたいというカップルには
ぴったしですよね
いませんか？　あれ？　いない？
（笑）
オーケー！　とにかく
このように声では
会話ができない状況でも
手話ならば 普通にいっぱい
しゃべることができるんです
これは本当に便利なので
是非是非 みなさんにも
おすすめしたいなって思っております
そして 手話の良いところは
まだまだ続きます
お次は こちら！
［手話の良いところ②］
表現力が高まるー！
皆さんは しゃべるときに
表情やジェスチャーを
意識していますか？
表情とジェスチャーが
あるのと無いのでは
伝わり方が大きく変わります
僕はさっきから手話を使って
しゃべっているんですけれども
表情とジェスチャーの要素が
いっぱいあるなって思いませんか？
それにはワケがあります
手話は手を動かすだけの
言葉ではないんです
自分の気持ちを視覚的に
表現しようと思ったら
手を動かすだけでは足りません
表情 体全体を使って
表すことが大事なんです
これは 実際に
例を見てもらいたいと思います
こちらです
［私は強い］
「私は強い」という文章があります
まずは 手の動きだけで表しますので
それをご覧ください
私は
強い
どうですか？
（笑）
なんか 怖いですよね？
感情無いと怖いですよね？
じゃあ 表情とジェスチャーを入れて
やってみたいと思います
もう一度ご覧ください
（三人）私は強い！
（三人）私は強いー！
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
やっぱり 表情とジェスチャーが
あるのと無いのでは
伝わり方が全く違いますよね？
あった方が絶対に良いと思いますよね？
手話っていうのは
こういう表情とジェスチャーが
セットになっている言語なんです
なので 手話を使っていると
自然に表現力が高まっていきます
表現力が高まれば きっと
職場でのプレゼンテーションにも
使えると思いますし
日常会話の中でも 自分の気持ちを
上手に相手に伝えられるように
なるんじゃないでしょうか？
と思っております
そして 手話の良いところは
まだまだ続きます
お次は こちら！
［手話の良いところ③］
人間関係が良くなるー！
皆さんは 誰かとしゃべるときに
ちゃんと相手の顔を見て
しゃべっていますか？
今の社会は 悲しいことに
お互いの顔を見て会話する人が
減ってきていると思います
スマホを触りながらしゃべったり
ゲームしながらしゃべったり
声の会話だと
相手の顔を見なくても
会話ができるので
ついついコミュニケーションが
雑になりがちなんだと思います
でも 手話の場合は
そうではありません
手話の場合は
見ないといけないので
手話を使って
会話をしようとすると
自然と相手の顔を見ながら
会話をするようになります
僕も友達としゃべるときは
必ず相手の顔を見てしゃべります
相手も僕の顔を見ながら
しゃべってくれます
このように お互いの顔を
見ながら会話をすると
いろんなことに気付くようになります
たとえば
自分がしゃべっているときに
自分がしゃべった言葉を
相手がどのように感じたのか
相手の表情の変化から
それを感じ取ることができます
また それだけではなく
あれ？　今日 髪型変えた？
あれ？　今日 疲れてる？
あれ？　なんかようわかんないけど —
いつもと違う？
（笑）
みたいに いつもとの変化にも
気付きやすくなると思うんです
また それ以外にも
やっぱり お互いの顔を
見ながら会話していると
自分の話をちゃんと聞いて
もらえているなっていう
安心感が生まれます
そして 相手が笑顔であれば
こっちも笑顔になりますし
相手が悲しい顔をしていたら
こっちも悲しい気持ちになります
その逆だって起こります
このように 手話っていうのは
共感しやすい言葉なんだって
僕は思っています
手話で会話をすることは
言葉と言葉をやり取りする
だけではありません
心と心のコミュニケーションを
することにも
繋がっていくと僕は思っています
良いコミュニケーションは
良い人間関係を作ります
皆さんが もし 手話を使って
周りの人とコミュニケーションを
取るようになったら
きっと 今以上に良い人間関係が
作っていけるようになるんじゃ
ないかなと思っております
そして 最後にもう１つだけ
言わせてください
最後はこちらです
［手話の良いところ④］
［楽しい］
今まで いろんなことを
話してきましたが
シンプルに「楽しい」っていうことも
手話の魅力の一つだと
僕は思っています
今は 劇、歌、ダンスと いろんな
エンターテインメントがありますが
手話を使った
パフォーマンスっていうのも
こういったエンターテインメントの
仲間に入るぐらいに
楽しいんじゃないかなって
僕は思っています
たとえば こんなふうに
（音楽）
（手拍子）
（石田）スリー ツー ワン！
（三人）フー！
（岡崎）オッケー！
ここからは 音楽に合わせて
手話を楽しむ時間ですよ！
（中川 石田）フー！
（岡崎）みなさんで一緒に
盛り上がっていきましょう！
（中川 石田）イエー！
（岡崎）さあ やり方は簡単ですよ
ミーたちの動きを見て 真似て
一緒に やってくれれば
（三人）オッケー！
（岡崎）さぁ 早速 最初の単語
いきましょう！
最初の単語は
（三人）こちら！
（岡崎）手話！
（中川 石田）手話！
［手話］
（岡崎）さぁ 人差し指を出して
そう 胸の前に持ってきて
グルグルー！
（中川 石田）グルグルー！
（岡崎）オッケー オッケー
じゃあ これを音楽に乗って
やってみますよ
ハイ！ ハイ！ ハイ！ ハイ！
（中川 石田）ワン ツー
ワン ツー スリー フォー
（岡崎）手話！
（中川 石田）手話！
（岡崎）手話 手話 手話 手話
（中川 石田）手話（×４）
（岡崎）手話！
（中川 石田）手話！
（岡崎）手話 手話 手話 手話
（中川 石田）手話（×４）
（三人）フー！
（拍手）
（岡崎）オッケー！
これで「手話」という
手話の表現はバッチリですね！
（中川 石田）フー！
（岡崎）さぁ 次の単語にいきましょう
次の単語は こちら！
楽しい！
（中川 石田）楽しい！
［楽しい］
（岡崎）さぁ 両手をパーにして
［手のひらを胸の前で上下に動かす！］
胸の前に持ってきて これを上下に
こう！
（中川 石田）こう！
（岡崎）オッケー！
笑顔が大事です！　笑顔！
（石田）オッケー！
ワン ツー スリー フォー
（岡崎）楽しい！
（中川 石田）楽しい！
（岡崎）楽しい 楽しい 楽しい 楽しい
（中川 石田）楽しい （×４）
（岡崎）楽しい！
（中川 石田）楽しい！
（岡崎）楽しい 楽しい 楽しい 楽しい
（中川 石田）楽しい（×４）
（三人）フー！
（拍手）
（岡崎）オッケー！
だんだん楽しくなってきましたね！
（手拍子）
さぁ 手話っていうのは
使っていないと忘れてしまう
悲しい言語です
なので 忘れないようにするためにも
繰り返し 繰り返し
使っていきましょう！
（石田）ワン ツー スリー フォー
（岡崎）手話！
（中川 石田）手話！
（岡崎）手話 手話 手話 手話
（中川 石田）手話（×４）
（岡崎）楽しい！
（中川 石田）楽しい！
（岡崎）楽しい 楽しい 楽しい 楽しい
（中川 石田）楽しい（×４）
（岡崎）手話！
（中川 石田）手話！
（岡崎）手話 手話 手話 手話
（中川 石田）手話（×４）
（岡崎）ハイッ 楽しい！
（中川 石田）楽しい！
（岡崎）楽しい！
（岡崎）楽しい 楽しい 楽しい 楽しい
（中川 石田）楽しい（×４）
（三人）フー！
（拍手）
（岡崎）オッケー！
（音楽終了）
（石田）ふー
（笑）
（岡崎）ふー
皆さん 手話は楽しかったですか？
（中川 石田）楽しい！
（拍手）
ありがとうございます！
手話っていうのは
聞こえない人が使う言語っていう
イメージが強いと思うんですけれども
手話っていうのは
聞こえない人だけではなく
聞こえる人にとっても
生活を便利にしてくれる
素敵なものだと 僕は思っています
なので 今日の話をきっかけに
たくさんの人が手話に興味を持って
聞こえる人と聞こえない人が
もっとたくさんコミュニケーション
できるようになれば
きっとお互いにとって
暮らしやすい社会に
変わっていくんじゃないかと
僕たちは思っています
もちろん 社会を変えるのは
簡単なことではないのは
わかっています！
でも
（三人）大丈夫！
（岡崎）今日 皆さんが
「手話は楽しい」って言ってくれたから
僕たちは 未来に
明るい希望を感じています
これからも僕たちは
この手話エンターテインメントを通して
たくさんの人に
手話の魅力を伝えていきます
そして いつの日か
聞こえる人と聞こえない人が
お互いに暮らしやすい社会を
必ずこの手で作ってみせます！
皆さんも是非 力を貸してください！
一緒に手話を盛り上げていきましょう！
ありがとうございました！
（中川 石田）ありがとうございました！
（拍手）